I'm going to name some guys on the
Celtics and I'm going to have you assign
them to a position on the football field
Jason Tatum wi receiver lanky range big
hands Drew holiday I'm going safety he's
a general on the floor he sees things
before they happen and I think that's
what I want my safeties to do Jaylen
Brown I'm putting him at running back
he's my running back and kind of slot
guy okay and last one Derek white
quarterback you want your quarterback to
go out there ball play in play out you
know he gives all the praise to
everybody else on this team he's also
performing at a very high Mark right now
but he just the first to credit I would
love my quarterback to that